today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpakman i put the link right below
this video
so the more we look at polling the more
we might think that joe biden and kamala
harris have this election in the bag but
consider for a moment that even if the
polls
are both perfectly accurate and don't
change
between now and election day what about
voter suppression
because the supreme court just showed us
that at least
three of the justices are more than
willing
to throw out absentee ballots and that
is not
priced into the polls in any way the
supreme court has reinstated
south carolina's witness signature
requirement for absentee ballots they
did this earlier this
week that alone is a decision that
could decide whether lindsey graham is
re-elected as a republican incumbent in
south carolina
or whether challenger jamie harrison
from the democratic party
removes incumbent lindsey graham that is
what the stakes are here and it means
that south carolinians including those
infected with coronavirus will once
again
need witnesses to sign their ballot
envelopes so think that through for a
second
you have coronavirus or you want to
avoid getting it you have it and want to
avoid spreading it or you shouldn't go
out
or you want to avoid getting it from
someone else you just want to be as safe
as possible
you request an absentee ballot beautiful
you get the absentee ballot perfect
you fill out the absentee ballot
correctly lovely
but before you send it in you need to
find a witness
to sign the envelope for you that says
it's really you voting it's really you
sending this thing in
it's pointless because that signature
could of course be forged
it risks spreading the virus and it will
almost
certainly lead to the nullification of
ballots
but that's not the worst of it it's even
worse
potentially because justices clarence
thomas
samuel alito and neil gorsuch would have
been willing not just to say that
these ballots going forward must have a
witness signature
but thomas alito and gorsuch actually
were ready to say
this rule should be applied
retroactively so
i really need people to understand this
clarence thomas samuel alito and neil
gorsuch
would be on board with saying ballots
already received by south carolina
election officials
before this decision was made about
witness signatures
those ballots should be thrown out even
though at the time that folks sent their
ballots in
this uh witness signature rule was not
yet the rule
it is outrageous and extreme and what it
signals to me is that
if indeed they get amy coney barrett
confirmed to the supreme court
and if indeed this entire presidential
election
starts to extend into november and
starts to involve
courts there are already three
amy coney barrett could be a fourth and
then you then it's just a question mark
what will john roberts do what will
others do
they are willing to actually interfere
in ways that are material these are not
theoretical things these are not things
that might have an impact but two or
four years from now this is right now
and had they gotten this rule past the
retroactive
requirement for witness signatures that
would have led to
i don't even know how many ballots being
thrown out that could have led
to lindsey graham winning even if jamie
harrison would otherwise have won i mean
we don't know that's going to be a tight
race and it's an uphill battle for jamie
harrison
but the point here is the trump
administration
is going to use this to their advantage
in any way that they can the trump
campaign has an army of lawyers ready to
do anything they can in any state they
can do it
to see what they can get away with biden
has a team of lawyers but are they ready
as i've said before it's much more
difficult to play defense
because you need to anticipate every
strategy that trump can use trump might
have ten different
strategies lawyers will use and biden's
lawyers might anticipate nine of them
and it could be that tenth one
that actually gets you in the end so
they really need to be prepared because
trump wants to win
trump at this point can only win by
preventing people from voting
by dissuading people from voting by
having people's votes not
counted and republicans have repeatedly
said in public that this is the plan
no one should be surprised now that they
are actually making the plan
a reality and if it comes to just a
couple of states
which it might and the supreme court
invalidates
hundreds of thousands of votes more than
that
will there be a revolt i actually think
you know i i
don't have uh i have what i think is a
realistic assessment that most people
can't afford to miss the next day of
work and most people are not going to
mass rally and go protest because
they have people to feed and money to
make and bills to pay and i understand
that
but i actually think that if it appears
as though
a supreme court with multiple justices
on it selected by donald trump
in starts invalidating votes and
potentially
flips the election to trump i do believe
there will be complete actual chaos in
the streets i believe we will see mass
rallies i
i i do believe that and i rarely am of
that mindset let me know what you think
uh it's it's continued bad news after
bad news for donald trump over the last
few days
a court ruled on wednesday that donald
trump can no longer block his tax
returns
from a subpoena in a grand jury in new
york and will have
to turn them over this is part of the
investigation into donald trump's
business practices and it's all falling
apart for him this was a 3-0 decision
in the second u.s circuit court of
appeals the decision is
trump must turn over his tax returns
great right so now the prosecution gets
the tax returns right
no not yet donald trump's lawyer jay
sekulow you might remember him from the
impeachment hearings
says that they will now appeal to the
supreme court
an agreement was reached where this
decision from the lower court
won't be enforced for almost a couple of
weeks
so that donald trump can appeal to the
supreme court
so bottom line these prosecutors
are not going to have trump's taxes
before the election
even if these prosecutors get donald
trump's taxes that doesn't mean that
we get them from them but something has
changed
we've already learned a ton about what
is in donald trump's taxes from that
bombshell new york times report from
i think it was about 10 days ago
although at this point it feels like six
months ago
where we learned that donald trump paid
no federal tax in ten of the last 15
years
we learned that donald trump paid only
750
in federal taxes in 2016 and only
another 750
in 2017 we learned that donald trump has
more than
420 million dollars in debt so the real
reason
that this decision matters is that trump
is clearly becoming unglued
and this won't help whether trump has
been experiencing
steroid-induced mania for the last few
days from the dexamethasone prescription
for his covid
or it's the polls that are triggering
him or whatever
he has been unhinged even by his
standards
and we may see i don't know what the
next week will bring i don't know what
this weekend will bring
by by by tuesday when we're back from
the holiday
donald trump may have already descended
into a full-blown
public narcissistic rage i was actually
thinking the other day
imagine if donald trump realized he
could go live on twitter
via video and imagine he just did it and
went live
and went completely crazy it would truly
be something else and what has been
sort of like a simmer for a few days is
quickly becoming a rolling boil
and it could be that way by election day
if things keep going going this way the
supreme court appointment now
appears as though it could be delayed
don jr reportedly thinks donald trump
needs an intervention
i don't yet believe that we've reached
the low point the sort of full bottom or
the full
climax really of donald trump's rage yet
and as far as the taxes go
the new york times themselves might have
more documents and may actually drop a
bombshell in the next couple of weeks
they may find a way remember that the
new york times decided they weren't
going to publish the actual tax
documents because
they believed that the copies they have
probably because of some markings or
stamps or whatnot that are on them
would expose who their source is on
trump's tax documents it's conceivable
that the source will say out me or
that the new york times will find a way
to release the documents without outing
the source and so we may even see the
actual tax documents before this is all
said and done
after this decision was made by the
court donald trump quickly went nuclear
within minutes of the decision he went
to twitter
to deliver another all-capital letters
rant where he said
wow now do something about this
the biggest of all political scandals in
history
biden obama and crooked hillary
led this treasonous plot biden shouldn't
be allowed to run
got caught now in all seriousness
as far as the appeal to the supreme
court on this decision
should the supreme court even hear this
case of course
it's the president and of course donald
trump has every right
to appeal each decision against him on
different grounds if that's what he
wants to do
but at some point does it become
frivolous different legal experts
have different perspectives on that but
i suppose
at some point we will see so the plan
for today and for next week we are going
to hear from some of you
we are going to talk later on in the
program about
whether trump's coronavirus helps or
hurts him
how long i believe it will take the
final results of the 2020 election to be
given
to us we will talk about the recent
trends with older voters moving towards
joe biden and away from donald trump
monday we are off call it columbus day
call it indigenous people's day
we tend to take federal holidays off the
staff really needs it so we will be off
on monday
and then back tuesday through election
day and it is going to be
a a wild wild few weeks so i'm glad that
you are
with me here make sure you're following
me on twitter at d pacman
membership always is the best way to
support our work and the show you can
grab a membership at joinpakman.com
and you have only about three and a half
weeks left to use
the coupon code 2020 now we started the
coupon code 2020 now
when i determined i used my judgment
to determine it is now the election the
election has started
that code will work until november 3rd
and then it is
bye-bye 2020 now saves you 66
off of the membership of your choice
grab one at jointpakman.com and we'll be
back right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to dot
com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the program remember
that the number one way
to support this show is by getting a
membership at joinpakman.com if you've
been looking at it very strongly or even
not this is a great time to do it go to
joinpakman.com
choose any membership you like monthly
or yearly if the price looks good
do it if you want a little bit of a
discount how about
66 percent off with the coupon code
2020 now that is all one word
all lowercase 2020 now
you will save 66 let's
pick up on some i guess we're still
calling them calls even though this week
they're from the david pakman show
discord let's see who wants to check in
today
let's go to chris from texas chris from
texas you were on what is on your mind
today my friend
hey hey david can you hear me i can hear
you perfectly
all right i called you about a couple of
months ago and i wanted to say
uh thank you for like teaching me how to
think more critically like
i remember thinking how i could thought
that biden was not gonna be able to win
yeah but looking at the polls from 538
it looks like it's pretty much
over for trump at this point i mean
biden would have
i don't have to literally about have to
die in order for
trump to win right now well listen i
hope that you are right
but all we need to do is just vote right
we ultimately have no control over
anything other than whether we vote so i
i love the optimism the polls look ugly
right now
but we just don't know in the 25 days
that are left we just don't know
so i share your cautious optimism let's
focus on the cautious and let's make
sure we vote
yeah i understand i'm going to vote i'm
going to vote next week's
uh tuesday as well beautiful
also so also i'm wondering too now like
with two of the
senate members testing positive for
coronavirus three in fact
oh three three now yeah well it's it's
mike lee
uh tom tillis and ron johnson yeah so do
you think it's possible that amy
comey's however he pronounced her name
amy coney barrett's
nomination will be delayed now i i do
think that there is a good chance that
it doesn't happen before
election day but if republicans are
determined
i don't see any way that it won't happen
during the period between the election
and the inauguration
my only hope is if the coronavirus
positives
prevent the vote from happening before
november 3rd
and then joe biden wins and democrats
take the senate and the martha mcsally
seat
is immediately seated because remember
that's a special election so mark if
mark kelly wins he might be seated right
away
i'm hoping that there would be such
outrage if republicans still try to push
it through i'm talking outrage to the
point of mass rallies and i don't know
if that will happen
that would be the dream scenario that
republicans abandon
the nomination it's very optimistic it's
very uphill but i think it's the only
chance we've got
also i'm kind of worried about packing
the courts as well
i thought i know people say that they
want to pack the courts just because
they want to at least be able to get
progressive reform yeah but i'm worried
that it could be used against us in the
future for republicans to pack the court
as well
it certainly could but here's here's
what i would say uh
here's what i would say to that chris
joe biden has
not answered whether he would or
wouldn't be in favor of that
and i think he's been smart not to
answer it for now because it would
whatever he answers will become the
focus and it's not really what this is
about
if you look back at joe biden's history
my reading of it is that he's unlikely
to pack the court so i actually if
you're concerned about that i don't
actually think biden will do it
okay my last question is what do you
think we should do
if joe biden becomes president should we
try to push him to for more left-wing
policies or should we just
try to undo all of the damage trump has
done first well it's both it's not one
or the other i mean a lot of the damage
trump has done
can be undone via executive order
executive orders and at the same time
particularly if democrats take the
senate then you've got
big legislative accomplishments that we
can start working on so you got to do
both
yeah all right thank you for the time
david chris i appreciate it so much
chris from texas great to hear from
christopher texas let's try once more
i'm i'm going to give him one other
opportunity
diego from mexico is back i don't know
what happened the first time
diego are you with us uh yes can you
hear me
david i i can hear you yes oh thank you
i thought my discord didn't work um it
works beautifully
yeah well it's the david pagman show
discord um
my question is about the star the stock
market and the recent plunge because
the news that trump is gonna halt well
halted all negotiations like
i i i can't understand what's the
political player here like
i i don't think there is one no i think
i think he i think he's on uh i think
he's on roid rage from the dexamethasone
it makes no sense and you know diego the
thing was
when when this all happened on tuesday
first trump tweets no second stimulus
and the stock market crashes
then the stock market closes and at
night
donald trump tweets if they get me a
bill to sign to send twelve hundred
dollar checks to people
i'll sign it and we'll send the checks
and then wednesday
the stock market goes up for 400 points
intraday
i don't know that donald trump you know
in general i
question how stable donald trump is
mentally
right now he seems particularly unstable
and it may be because of the medications
he's on but you're completely right
sending checks to people is the la it's
the hail mary it's the last chance trump
has to try to win some votes back
why would he abandon it it makes no
sense
exactly even uh right uh right leading
paul
rasmussen has him down i believe 12
points yeah
and the only explanation i've heard is
that he's
taking the country hostage and saying if
i don't win
you can't even get the stimulus right
because of the lame duck period
so even then you have to wait the only
way you can get a relief
soon is if you vote for me but i don't
know well the crazy thing about this is
that
although it's true that if biden wins
trump probably won't do any stimulus
during the lame duck just despite people
in the long run
biden is likely to in total do something
better for the average person than
whatever trump is dangling now so it's
not it's it's a threat and of course
people will have to figure out what to
do for the next four months
but in the longer term if biden does win
people will be much better off
exactly i i can't even i can't even see
it from
uh trump's side but it makes no sense
yeah
yeah well uh thank you for taking
michael and
salud mexico all right very much saludos
and
appreciate the call hope to speak to you
soon that's diego
from mexico let's go next to usman
from karachi usman you're on
usman
usman from karachi i heard background
noise what's going on
hello yes
can you actually hear me i can hear you
oh damn
like a few months ago like uh
the caller from pakistan i do remember
yes is is my voice better than it was
last time you know your voice is
sounding okay yeah
oh okay cool cool um
okay i i i wanted to ask you a question
basically
you're still on no okay okay uh
i basically wanted to ask you a question
about
um latin american politics so you've uh
you've criticized like many uh
authoritarian
leftist leaders like you know fidel
castro
hugo showers uh all those guys
but like do you think that
in your opinion like were there any
other like
uh center left to uh
to further left like uh leaders
like for example lula or jose mojica
in uh boy like do you think like they
were
in uh any uh any better or like
uh like there was like this woman and
do you think they were like any better
leaders
absolutely absolutely so while there are
certainly overlaps between someone like
hugo chavez
and jose muhika in uruguay
there is a it is really night and day in
total
and jose mujica is someone that i um
uh would would be is much closer to my
politics and it doesn't mean i would
agree with him on everything but
no question about it and you know when
people say david you're
you're just some you're really a right
winger you know
what whatever no i'm i'm an
anti-authoritarian
and while jose mujica might have some
particular views that i don't agree with
he was not an authoritarian the way hugo
chavez was and so for sure
for sure i consider them different
categories altogether
okay can i ask you another question
sure uh
okay okay okay one uh one second i
i feel i forgot oh yeah well listen i've
got a lot of people waiting so call back
again
um we we if you forgot the question
let's let's move on because there are
lots of people who do
who do want to chat today uh i'm going
to go
next to um james from new york
james from new york you were on with me
uh what's what's going on in new york
these days
james from new york you're on
hello that's you hey you can hear me
yes i can david hi yeah my name is uh
james i'm actually an er doctor who just
uh graduated uh out of new york city
great um i've got a question for you
i'm wondering sort of all of these
different issues
abortion rights gay rights
build the wall any sort of issue like
this
i almost feel like we're sort of missing
the forest for the trees
and the idea that like unless we get
money out of politics register everybody
in the country to vote
it sort of seems like this system is
going to continue to stay
broken and that there's no way that we
can
fix it unless we fix these sort of like
the electoral college money in politics
absolutely correct yeah so i've said for
a while that whatever you care about
whether it's abortion
education um whatever your issue is gay
rights
tax rates you know whatever the case may
be there's a package of meta issues that
need to be dealt with it's a more
systemic
issue that includes money in politics
and
combined with money in politics it's the
way media operates which is very much
influenced by money in politics
we have to deal with how elections are
done so we're talking about you know
electoral college is a problem
55 percent voter turnout in presidential
elections is a problem that's a really
big
first pass the post is a problem got to
deal with that and then number three
climate climate actually is a meta issue
a lot of people don't consider
but if your city's underwater or you're
in the hospital
because of the pollution in your city
it's hard to be an activist
when that is is the the situation in
terms of climate and honestly
even though health care is a political
issue if you don't have health care and
you're sick
it's also going to be hard to be an
activist so those are kind of like the
four meta issues that
if we really want to fix things you have
to deal with you're spot on
yeah it sort of seems like it's a
beautiful system that has
been created to sort of basically
distract
the everyday voter from these
generalized problems and just get them
focused on
oh well everyone else is lazy or
you know you need to just man up and get
over your issues
and that nobody it's almost like the
rats fighting over the scraps while the
one percent just convince
basically convinces conservatives to
vote for rich people keeping their money
yeah a lot of times what what i
recommend to people is when you're in
you're embroiled in a po
you're thinking about a political issue
or you're embroiled in a political
debate ask yourself whether you're even
debating the right question so for
example the debate over to what degree
can people pull themselves up by their
bootstraps
it's a ridiculous debate we we know the
answers we have data on class mobility
we have data on the impact of not having
you know having hunger
or of not having health care and the
effect that this has on class mobility
it's it's the wrong debate and it might
be fun for you know
people who go and speak at colleges and
argue with college kids or whatever the
case may be but um
we know that these meta issues are an
impediment to solving
any of these problems when it comes
right down to it
so i guess my question is how do we
solve this
like really like how do we even fix this
country
i mean as a starting point if we don't
actually get competent leadership
controlling the white house the house
and the senate and most of the
governor's mansions
for at least four years and make some
progress
it's going to be very difficult and
that's again the system is meant to
perpetuate itself it's almost
it's almost like natural selection in a
sense the system survives because it's
most likely to perpetuate itself
and it perpetuates itself because it
survives it's a circle
yeah yeah i couldn't agree more i have
all these conversations with different
people
of different sort of socioeconomic and
racial backgrounds
and it just seems like emotion takes
over
and no real rational discussions take
place it's like your political party is
your team
right and not actually is this
benefiting you
and i just i like honest to god i'm
really
in fear on november and they have this
election and
trump's going to declare victory and
what is
you know 50 million people or whatever
who voted for them
what do you do when your president says
i've won and if they try and take it
from me you need to take to the streets
that's that that's my fear exactly
listen before i let you go as an er
doctor
what is going on in in ers at this point
what are you seeing
um so it's it sort of depends on where
you are
but at least in the around the new york
city area cases are starting to spike
again yeah um it seems like i
don't want to you know you know single
out
a single group but it seems like it's
religious gatherings
and it's nursing homes and they're just
sort of like relaxing standards
and the numbers are especially around
the city
they're starting to rise and we are
either everybody who got super sick
already got sick and we're gonna be okay
or we're gonna do the same thing we did
back in march and april
and i don't know how health care
workers and the general populace i don't
know how we get through it if we do the
same thing that happened back in march
so when you tell someone hey you have
coronavirus
are are people surprised in the sense
that they're not connecting their
actions to getting the virus
um well yeah sort of
um it's also difficult just explaining
to people in general
that because the prevalence of this
virus is so low that a negative test
doesn't mean anything um you could have
five negative tests and you could still
have the virus
um that's just based on like statistics
with the prevalence being so low
um it's just hard because it also
matters how you do the test
and a lot of health care people don't
want to shove that swab
super deep up the nose so it's a
negative test but maybe it's really not
negative
um yeah it's and you know we still have
a lot of the tests in a lot of these
hospitals are taking six hours to come
back
right he got sitting in the er for six
hours
it's i mean it's almost as if everything
we went through in march
changed nothing about how we're handling
it right from
leadership in the hospitals to the
statewide to the national level
it's really scary to be honest with you
hey last thing
and then i gotta run are you're in the
er you're not actually doing any
coronavirus treatment right like
the any if people are getting anything
from rendez-severe to dexamethasone or
anything like that that's once they've
been admitted
well so usually what happens is if we
suspect and they look
bad we'll start a couple of these
treatments
um but if they're looking okay you just
swab them
make sure there's no other pneumonia or
other sort of infection
and then you just send them home with
quarantine precautions oh i see
um yeah but it's sort of hard to say i
know the steroids help but it's usually
only it's sicker people
but the ones that sort of look sick or
throwing the mack truck at him because
we really don't know what this virus
does yeah what's that
all right james from new york i
appreciate you uh talking to us today
it's a pleasure thanks for having me on
i love your show there's james from new
york er doctor we're going to take a
quick break if you are holding
don't hang up because we will go right
back to the phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right many people who want to get on
with me today i want to hear from
some of them let's go first here to
marta from miami florida marta what is
on your mind today
hello hello yes i can oh
what are you actually thinking about i'm
i live in miami florida martha you're
cutting in and out all right so so we
your i can barely hear you i heard you
live in miami and then you immediately
cut out
so most of my family is cuban-american
and they keep using the argument that
biden is a communist and he's a
socialist
and i just want to know what can i say
to them or if you have like a good
article you can recommend
just so i can like butt that argument
listen i have not seen
anybody seriously be able to answer the
question
which biden policy is a socialist
policy so i'd be curious if you were to
say
okay let's let's actually examine that
what biden policy is a socialist policy
usually that falls apart and then they
move on to a different
argument which maybe would be easier to
deal with
yeah because i tell them i'm like you
know it's not it's not going to be like
that they're like no it's going to be
like cuba and we're going to be you know
struggling for food with like a libretto
i'm like listen i mean
was it like cubo when barack obama was
president for eight years because
joe biden was the vice president if it
wasn't like cuba during those eight
years why would it be like that under
joe biden
yeah and then they bring up you know the
whole cuban missile crisis and kennedy
and it's just
uh what does that happen joe biden what
you know i think in a lot of these
here what you're getting to marta is
that in a lot of these situations
it's not really about you explaining the
truth it's about just coming up with
something to say
so they can perpetuate their own
misunderstandings
and you might i mean it could go that
way it could go
biden's a socialist and you say well
what's one socialist policy
they say well it's just it's gonna
become like cuba and then you would say
well
was it like cuba when obama was
president and then they would say yeah
but look at what kennedy did during the
cuban missile crisis now we're
50 years ago right it's they don't
really
want to know anything and sometimes you
have to just acknowledge that
yeah that's basically been the exact
argument for months and months and
months
that i i don't envy you marta and you
know for people who are calling in and
may not know
the american uh hispanic community
is a very left-wing community in total
but the the most conservative
sub-section
of latin americans is cuban-americans
and it is usually this reflexive
anti-castro thing that the ones who came
to the u.s
were against the castro regime they
associate the castro regime with
democrats
why i don't know and you end up in
situations like marta's situation
okay thank you very much all right great
to hear from you marta appreciate uh
appreciate the call let's go next
to uh there's just so many people who
want to get on here it's very very
interesting
um why don't we go to let's go to
adam from dubai adam from dubai what's
going on
hey what's good david how you doing
pretty good
i've been a fan of the show for a while
what's uh
what's it like in dubai right now
um pretty hot uh it's getting a lot
better
but uh just dealing with this whole
covet thing
yeah all right well what can i do for
you today
yeah i like i i don't know if a lot of
americans know like how much the
election
impacts this part of the world but um
like we tend to keep up with it a lot
and like i'm just wondering like given
because to me like it seems like it's a
clear choice between biden and trump
but there's still like a lot of both
sizes that i still see
yeah especially like in progressive uh
circles
i'm just wondering like what the
rationale behind that is
there's a there's a bunch of different
things going on there's not one answer
so you certainly have people
who so in terms of undecideds the
typical
undecided is center-right
relatively young and not paying
attention very closely so most of the
undecideds or people that could go
either way are not people that are on
the left that's important to understand
among those who are on the left and are
unsure
you have a contingent that just doesn't
like joe biden that that would be just a
very specific thing like okay trump
aside i don't like biden so i'm not
going to vote for biden
you have the both sides ists who say
if it's not a quote true progressive i
don't care whether it's trump or biden
we saw in 2016 how that failed us trump
now has had two and
potential potentially will get a third
supreme court pick so you have that
contingent
um you have people who uh would be open
to vote
open to voting for joe biden but want to
feel as as though joe biden came and
got their vote and earned their vote and
for me
you know i don't need that i just look
at biden's policy and i see oh biden's
policy is better i'll vote for biden and
it's sort of that simple so you've got a
lot of different
things on the left going on at once but
most people are going to vote for biden
that's the reality some of these
anti-biden left-wing enclaves they're
very loud online
but most people realize what's going on
sure uh like i mean i'm not concerned
about
like individuals you know write a post
or whatever but
like seeing online commentators like
that i won't name
uh on on the left uh essentially still
stick to their guns on this
and when you say stick to their guns
what are their guns just that biden's
bad and you shouldn't vote for him
yeah like so saying that no one won the
debate and saying that hey
like you know the american people still
uh like will lose
no matter who wins like trying to muddy
the waters
and a clear choice yeah and that sounds
irresponsible to me because
if there's a better choice you go with
the better choice you know it's sort of
like
if you really believe that we're talking
about two bad choices
isn't there a moral responsibility to
act in the way that
that pushes the the less bad choice like
if you say to me would you
rather have a sinus infection
or covid and maybe the covid gets really
serious
i'm not looking for either but given the
choice i would say give me the sinus
infection you know sure
yeah and and also like i don't
understand the uh
uh like i don't i don't feel like we
have the luxury to play those games of
like
oh i want to bite indicator to me or i
want him to do such and such
right given how terrible the situation
really is
i completely agree with you all right
cool
all right thanks david all right adam
from dubai great to hear from you there
there he is adam from dubai let's go
next to hayden from
morgantown west virginia hayden from
morgantown west virginia you are on
what is on your mind uh not much um i
just want to ask you some questions
about down ballot races
sure yeah so currently like out of the
united states like if you just like
in no particular state what are like
what down ballot races right now are you
most interested in
really for me it's the ones that could
flip the senate to democrats so
you know i mean certainly as a starting
point i'm looking at susan collins in
maine who's facing sarah
a challenge from sarah gideon i'm
looking at martha mcsally in arizona
who's facing a challenge for mark kelly
the tom tillis cal cunningham race in
north carolina steve bullock in montana
the joni ernst race in iowa is
interesting jamie harrison
versus lindsey graham corey gardner
looks like he's going to lose in
colorado
that that's where my focus is yeah um
currently at least in my state we're we
have a race between shelly moore capital
and apology and swearingen
it's been pretty interesting since i
like in the state
like we're not like we have a history of
progressive politics
although like it's been a while since
like an actual like progressive
politician has made it this far
since like we have like joe manchin as
our um current
vp and it's very interesting to see how
this happens uh
yeah i'm interested i mean now i i am
interested to see how that uh
how that goes i think the implications
of for
the balance of power are less
significant but an interesting race
nonetheless
you almost had a pretty progressive
person win for our in our um
governor primary but he made it very
close although the polls came down to it
was like about a two
it was like a two percent difference it
was very close hayden what's it like
living in west virginia i've never had
the pleasure of visiting the state and
you know you hear a lot of different
things
what what's the experience like uh yeah
in the states
it's actually pretty interesting since
people usually assume it's just like
backwoods hillbilly areas
right although like in which in all
fairness a lot of the state is like that
although there are two main cities like
morgantown where i live it's like a
college town it's like pretty vibrant
um and there's also charleston which is
a very nice city um
sadly like our population numbers are
going down pretty significantly
throughout most of the state
like i believe we're like the fastest
shrinking states although we do have a
few towns which are growing which is
nice
so like in morgantown for example would
you be able to go
to a are are there like pretentious
third wave coffee shops and stuff
uh yeah there are some interesting
coffee shops um i don't wanna like
there's actually one
like relatively close to me like the
tara cafe like they're by the water it's
like
since there's college students it's like
it's like a bit more of like a younger
audience for those
right areas but like in the like
charleston also has some like more like
semi like hipstery like shops and stuff
although overall it's like like the
population is generally older in the
state
like younger people tend to go to other
areas all right well it sounds like
you're doing okay there then
yeah all right hayden appreciate hearing
from you hope to hear from you again
yeah thank you for your time david all
right there is hayden from west virginia
uh and then let's go to why don't we go
oh i don't know i mean there's just so
many so many different people who want
to get on here
why don't we try uh let's try
steven from pretoria steven from
pretoria what's on your mind
steven from pretoria you were on
oh hi david peckman how are you good how
are you
i can't complain uh i have a few
questions
all right uh my first question is like
why would trump make these very very bad
decisions
um regarding the handling of his own
health well what is what would you be
your opinion
my opinion is that it was uh that there
was a bigger picture effort
probably to try to hide the fact that he
had coronavirus at all
and that was the initial plan when he
got too
sick for that they were already they had
fallen behind
on the management of it and then it just
led to bad decision after bad decision
once he was in the hospital
he could have been like on a roid rage
due to the dexamethasone
precipitating even worse decisions i
think it's some combination of that
yeah i think i think this is turning out
very bad for him
it would have turned out better for him
if he was in the hospital because i
think he would have gotten a little bit
more sympathy but it's possible
it's already it's already going bad so
he's trying to
like manage a dumpster fire uh
second question uh how do you think
america will handle the new evangelicals
if like let's say if biden becomes
president because
i think it's it's it's becoming a
problem like all over the world
especially we're
here in south africa handle them in what
way
i'm not sure i know what you mean handle
the new evangelicals in what sense no
not new
like neo like no neo
well i mean listen um i i think that
we've seen this really weird thing under
trump where
evangelicals who normally would never
even consider voting for someone like
trump if he were a democrat voted for
him because he wasn't hillary
and then we'll see this november what
they do in terms of biden versus trump
but i think overwhelmingly they will
still support trump
i think if biden wins there won't be
much to do with the neo-evangelicals
because they'll go back to supporting
anti-abortion anti-gay sort of more
traditional religious conservatism
and and uh and that will be that i don't
predict anything different will happen
oh okay well thank you thank you for
having me it's like it's first time
i was very anxious and very nervous but
thank you very much steven you did great
i appreciate you being on that's going
to do it for today i hope to hear
from more people next week thank you the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
let's get into audience questions for
the week i've been getting a lot of
these
types of questions which essentially
amount to
what is the impact of donald trump
having coronavirus
on the presidential race does it help
him does it hurt him what about a
sympathy vote what about people who will
see him
as getting the virus because he's
irresponsible so we have to divide this
into
a few different categories of people and
a few different
scenarios so let's first get out of the
way the more sort of legalistic
scenarios if trump were to become very
sick again and again we don't yet
know what the the course of his disease
will be
this week doctors have been saying he's
doing great by the time you watch this
or listen to this clip he may be doing
poorly it's just
all so dishonest and so erratic that we
don't know
but if trump gets very sick ends up on a
ventilator
mike pence becomes acting president does
mike pence become the top of the ticket
who are people really voting for
very impossible to predict how it would
change the dynamic of the race
but my guess would be that might almost
help the republican ticket in that
the idea of a steadier person
coming in pence might be more appealing
to some republicans than re-electing
donald trump but it's very unpredictable
if trump were to die before the election
we are in
outlandish marginal territory and
who knows what would happen but assuming
that donald trump remains alive and it
does not become incapacitated due to a
resurgence of the virus
my instinct is that anybody
who would vote based on whether their
candidate
gets the virus is already voting for
donald trump and what i mean by that is
anybody who would say well
if you get the virus you're weak those
people are already voting for donald
trump and they're going to continue
voting for donald trump
if you vote based on policy uh
and you're concerned about the handling
of coronavirus you're almost certainly
already voting for joe biden
the only way in which trump's
coronavirus
case would affect voters in my mind
would be that trump getting the virus
in addition to chris christie kaylee
mcinanny
trump's campaign manager hope on and on
and on
it is part of the story not of
individual contagion
but of the mishandling of coronavirus
more broadly by this administration that
they've been so careless and reckless
that while almost no prominent democrats
have become infected
all of these prominent republicans
including people around trump
it's the needle uh it's the straw that
breaks the camel's back so to speak in
terms of the mishandling of the virus
those are people who might be inclined
to vote for biden or at least not for
trump as a result but it's sort of like
an indirect effect
of trump getting the virus overall
it seems bad for trump um although
again it's all so erratic but
it seems as though donald trump plans to
be
at the second debate it seems as though
donald trump is relatively recovering
although much of it may be driven by
steroids that that he's on which can
create
you know feelings of euphoria or or a
feeling great it appears as though
the debate the post-debate
post-diagnosis polls we are getting
are really really bad for donald trump
and my bottom line assessment is it's
not good for trump
it may not be that bad but the
coronavirus episode is not good for
trump
next question today is hey david trump
is talking about not knowing the results
of this election for days weeks or
months when do you think we will know
who won the 2020 election
so about um three weeks ago i would have
said to you
it could be seven days after november
third so like by november 10th we will
know the results
with every passing day i actually think
we will probably know the results
not much later than november 4th i think
the day after the election
i don't believe this is going to be
close enough
that we will need a full week to know
the results now
if and whether donald trump concedes if
he loses
that's a very different question but i
am increasingly
when you look at there are basically the
issue is absentee ballots
in a normal election according to the
brookings institute
about 30 percent of the ballots that are
cast would be expected to be mailed in
it is now expected to be more than half
and there are basically
three scenarios for when states can
count absentee ballots
states can just start counting as they
come in before election day meaning
they're already counting mail-in ballots
in some states
there are states where the absentee
ballots can start to be counted uh
at the in the morning before the polls
close
even if they have been mailed in so
november 3rd in the morning people start
voting in person and they start opening
and counting absentee ballots
and then the third scenario is only when
the polls
close can you start counting absentee
ballots
the vast majority of states
that matter are not in that last
category and i
it escapes me now but there are two
states
i i want to say pennsylvania and one
other
of the states that are in the last
category where the results may take a
while to have
from the absentee ballots there are very
few that have a shot at making a
difference in the results now
pennsylvania certainly is one of them
and the reason why i am
increasingly thinking it's not going to
take a week to know the results
is that pennsylvania is going more and
more in the direction of joe biden
this week in fact we had polls saying
joe biden is up eight in pennsylvania
or even more and that is the one
there may be one other that is one of
the few states that could be a deciding
state
that has this we don't start counting
until the polls close sort of uh
scenario and i i may even be
misremembering that
bottom line the the gist is
uh i think the election results being
delayed
will have more to do with whether donald
trump
successfully uses lawyers and courts
to slow down or stop the counting of
absentee ballots
and or to get ballots dismissed which he
successfully did
in iowa this week or last week i think
it will have more to do with that
than the actual time it will take to
count the ballots i think that if the
ballots are allowed to be counted
um normally without interference
that this is going to be an election
where we know the results on november
4th now that could be like midnight
as november 5th is starting i think the
real chance for a delay
would be donald trump creating one
through using lawyers courts lawsuits
and the like
let's hope it doesn't happen let's hope
it is so
a blowout for joe biden which depends on
us
that it doesn't even matter that even on
election night it becomes clear that
joe biden won it could happen it could
happen
the next few weeks will determine
ultimately what does happen
last question today david why are older
voters abandoning trump
last week you you talked about why rural
white older voters
like trump but now they're abandoning
him why is it
basically three reasons appear to be
what's going what's really
hurting donald trump in the last week
this is new
before this week we knew trump's
handling of coronavirus was hurting him
in general
and hurting him with older voters
trump's handling of the economy as a
result of coronavirus meaning the
economic destruction was worse than it
had to be because of trump's mishandling
of
coronavirus that is hurting trump with
older voters but we now in addition
have the issue of debate performance the
post debate
polls by donald trump the post debate
polls
that account for donald trump trump's
performance in the debate
are a disaster for trump specifically
among older voters older voters
in some polls are no longer even the
demographic group
age-wise that most supports trump
there's a new poll
i think it was the cnn poll from this
week where
the under 35 crowd is actually
trump's strongest group from the
standpoint of age and what's going on
is that for a lot of older folks
coronavirus is not
abstract certainly if you're in a
nursing home
and you see people dying and you see the
chaos
it is not numbers you check once a day
it is very real
if you simply know people not
nursing home related who aren't doing
well and of course
because it disproportionately affects
older folks those are the folks most
likely to have
friends and people in their circle that
are suffering directly
and then you see trump go on television
and say it's like a flu
it's no big deal we've turned the corner
our mark we're getting great marks
you see the obvious lies and you know
well
you know blanche died and joe died how
is trump saying this your friends are in
icus
um that is going to create a problem for
you and then when on top of it you start
looking
you know at your retirement account or
you're on a fixed income or
trump's talking about cutting funding to
social security by a payroll tax
deferral
it's not good and pretending that this
was a hoax
was a very bad idea the statistics don't
lie we said in may
when trump started transitioning into we
beat it
that that might work in june and july
but it's not going to work forever and
it's not been working
and then you add to the fact that
hillary clinton was less liked than joe
biden
joe biden by and large particularly
for uh older white folks
is much more likable than hillary
clinton he's the type of guy
most people would like to sit down and
just talk to
many older voters would identify with
joe biden
guy who grew up working class likes
trains
has suffered significant personal loss
and so on and so forth then you look at
trump and he's just a rude
disgusting guy who yelled the entire
debate so all of that together
tells us seniors are paying attention
they're not willing to die for the
economy
like the what was his name dan roberts
or dan patrick the uh
lieutenant governor of texas said early
on in this thing
and they're paying attention they're
paying attention to what's going on
trump already going into all of this was
doing less well with seniors than many
previous republicans had done
now it's gotten even worse he's got the
latest polls in the last
96 hours are very very bad and hopefully
every single
one of these groups will completely
repudiate donald trump in a
brutal brutal defeat but it's up to us
to make it happen
and we're going to try to do that
exactly and we will continue pushing
next week and the week after and the
week after that and then
hopefully we'll have a new
president-elect
we have a great bonus show for you today
remember
you can get instant access not an hour
from now
not 20 minutes from now instant access
to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try
blinkist for free and save 25
off of a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've also included the link
right underneath this video